[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
فرق الاغاثه والانقاذ غائبه عن اكثر من 20
قريه في ريف حماه الشمالي وسكانها ما
يزالون تحت الانقاض
قتل الزلزال في تركيا يتجاوزون سته
وثلاثين الفا والاضرار المباشره تقدر بنحو
خمسه وعشرين مليار دولار
مجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه تكشف ان
البرنامج النووي الايراني تجاوز
الاحتياجات المدنيه
منها العصاب اللي حاكمه عصابه محتاجون
يضربون النار في واجهات عدد من البنوك
اللبنانيه احتجاجا على احتجاز ودائعهم
وتدهور سعر العمله
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه 11
يوما على الزلزال المدمر في سوريا وتركيا
احد عشر يوما وما تزال بعض القرى في سوريا
دون اي فرق انقاذ لرفع الضحايا من تحت
الانقاض
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان اعلن ان حجم
الكارثه اكبر بكثير من الامكانيات
المتوفره وان هناك الكثير من المفقودين في
المناطق المنكوبه وان مصيرهم ما زال
مجهولا
المرصد اعلن ايضا ان عدد ضحايا الزلزال من
السوريين في تركيا وسوريا وصل الى
7328 قتيلا مؤكدا ان هناك الكثير من قتل
الزلزال دفنوا بدون تسجيلهم في المستشفيات
البيانات الرسميه الصادره من النظام اوضحت
ان عدد القتلى في المناطق التابعه لسيطرته
وصل الى اكثر من
1400 قتيل فيما كانت ارقام ضحايا الزلزال
الصادره من جماعات المعارضه السوريه تشير
الى
2274 قتيلا
ماساه الزلزال في سوريا لم تخلو من سجالات
واتهامات بين القوى السياسيه بشان تجاهل
مناطق عديده دمرها الزلزال وقتل وجرح فيها
المئات من سكانها انا فاقد مندي ولاده
حمايل وكذا ولد كمان يعني مين مجموعه
حوالي 25 شخص فجاه بتهتز الدنيا
تنزل بنايه مثل الطابق البسكوت
وبنته وبنته وراحوا
قصص نقلها المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان عن
الاهالي هناك وقال ناشطون فيها ان ما خلفه
الزلزال من دمار لم يكن في الحسبان
فقد طال الزلزال احدى وعشرين قريه على طول
خط كامل في ريف حلب الجنوبي وصولا الى ريف
حماه الشماليه تلك المناطق تخضع لسيطره
النظام وميليشيات ايرانيه بقيت اياما
تعاني الماساه دون مساعده تذكر
ابرزها سراقب ابو الظهور والحاضر ومعره
النعمان يقول الاهالي ربما كان النظام
وميليشياته يقصدون تجاهلها بعد ان ظلت
عصيه لنحو سبعه اعوام لكن النظام عزا
الامر لضعف الامكانيات
ايضا قرى في عفرين وخاصه بلده جنديرس التي
تكتظ بمهجرين سوريين وتخضع لسيطره فصائل
المعارضه والجيش التركي لم يصلها احد
فتكفل الاهالي بدفن ضحاياهم الى جانب قرى
بريف جبله والقدموس بريف اللاذقيه تعرضت
للتجاهل ما اضطر قاطنيها الى التصرف
بامكانات محدوده
وتقول منظمات انسانيه وحقوقيه ان معظم
القرى التي تم تجاهلها من قبل النظام
والمعارضه تعاني من الفقر وابسط مقومات
الحياه ناهيك عن البنايات التي شيدها
مقاولون وانهارت في اللحظات الاولى من
الزلزال بسبب الغش بمواد البناء
معي من مدينه كوفنتري البريطانيه رامي عبد
الرحمن وهو مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان اهلا وسهلا بك مجددا عبر العربيه
اولا اخر تحديث وصل قم لعدد الضحايا سواء
قتل او جرحى وماذا عن هذه القرى في ريف
حماه الشمالي واعدادها اكثر من 20 هل صحيح
ان فرق الانقاذ والاغاثه غائبه تماما عنها
ام لا هذا كلام غير صحيح
نعم نعم مساء الخير طبعا ولكن بعد ايام
بعد ان كان هناك دفن للضحايا او تمكن
الاهالي من اخراج بعض الذين فارقوا الحياه
من تحت الانقاض ترى متناثره حقيقه الامل
بالريف حلب الجنوبي وصولا الى ريف حماه
الشمالي مرورا بشرق السكه انه ما يعرف
بمناطق شرق ادلب التي تسيطر عليها
ميليشيات ايران وتسيطر عليها ميليشيات
عشائريه ولا النظام يتواجد فيها تتواجد
فيها قوات النظام في بعض النقاط المتناثره
هذا بالنسبه
للاحصائيه نشرناها مساء المؤكده حق اللحظه
خمسه الاف وستمائه وخمسين هؤلاء من الذين
دفنوا يعني توفوا داخل سوريا ودفن داخل
سوريا اذا ما الرقم الذي وصل حتى صباح
اليوم من تركيا نتحدث عن سوريين قتلوا في
زلزال ودخلوا داخل التراب السوري
7,353 لانه هناك 17
جاء بهم عبر عده معابر من الاراضي التركيه
اغلبتهم جاؤوا من معبر باب الهوى وبعضهم
جاء من بعبر الحمام معبر الراعي معبر
جرابلس ومعبر باب السلامه
هل صحيح ان كثير من الجثث السوريين لم يتم
تسجيلها جرى دفنها بشكل سريع دون ان يتم
تسجيلها في القيود ام لا هذا كلام ايضا
غير صحيح لا لا كلام صحيح هذا الكلام يعني
حالات نحن عايشناها
نحن انا اتحدث كان هناك احد نشطاء المرصد
انا اعتقد بانه فارق الحياه
بالدمار الذي حصل في ادلب بدفن يعني
اقاربه في الساعات الاولى من الزلزال يعني
الساعه 7:00 صباحا صار لي حفرنا القبور
ودفنا خمسه من اسره وارسل لي صور القبور
التي تم دفن فيها الاناث وايضا في ريف ريف
جنديرس عده قرى جرى دفن جسامين الذين قضوا
في الزلزال قبل ان تصل اليهم فرق طبيه او
فرق انقاذ هذا يعني ليس لوما على فرق
الانقاص في تلك المناطق ولكن الواقع بان
فرق الانقاذ مجتمعه واصل بهيئه التح الشام
حتى ابو عمشه فهم يعني ابو عمشه ايضا هو
فاهم بقضيه الانقاص ولكن حجم الزلزال كان
كبير جدا واكبر من امكانياتها اولاد يعني
جاءت يعني انت جرابلس في اكثر حلب الشمالي
الشرقي جهه باليات بالجرابلس كي تعمل في
جنديرس بعد عده الساعات بعد عده الساعات
يكون الامر
موضوع ما جرى ايضا في
ايرث في الساعات او في اليوم الاول او في
اليوم الثاني قيل باننا تمكنا من العمل في
12 مبنى وعدد المباني التي هدمت بشكل كامل
هي 74 80 مبنى لان هناك من كانت تحت
الانقاذ بقيت تحت الانقاذ او من تم انقاذ
اخراج
اخرج استاذ رامي بالنسبه الى من لا يزال
مصيرهم مجهولا تحديدا في هذه القرى في ريف
حما الشمالي واعداده اكثر من 20 هل صحيح
ان معظم السكان ما زالوا تحت الانقاض ام
لا يعني هذه من المبالغات وكلام غير صحيح
الشمالي بشكل قطعي حسب القرى وحسب الترتيب
وحسب البلدات هناك اكثر من 500 ضحيه توفوا
قبل ان تصل اليهم قوات النظام والمضحك بان
احصائيه من 1400 واحصائيه الامم المتحده
نتحدث عن 4500 بمناطق النظام ان جبله
لوحدها او محافظه اللاذقيه يكون دقيقين
فيها اكثر من 805 من الضحايا حمل لوحدها
يوجد فيها ايضا اقارب رئيس وزراء النظام
يوجد فيها 183 ضحيه بالاسم وحلب وغيرها من
المناطق النظام تفضل طيب من مدينه
كوفنتريال البريطانيه رامي عبد الرحمن
مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان شكرا
جزيلا لك استاذ رامي على هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
يوم الاثنين
حوالي
اتفقنا على هزه الارض عندي الولاد نايمين
بغرفه ثانيه
على الحيطان الحيص بالبيت
يعني الاولاد من الهزه قوه الهزه
شو بدنا نساوي
وطلعنا برا البيت
[موسيقى]
اول ما بلشت الهز الارضيه
وفي تركيا اعلنت اداره الكوارث التركيه
ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الى اكثر من 36
الفا واشارت في بيان لها الى اجلال اكثر
من 216 الف شخص من المناطق المتضرره من
الزلزال واضافت انها رصدت اكثر من 4,300
هزه ارتداديه بعد الزلزال الاول في السادس
من فبراير
ورغم فقدان الامل باخراج احياء من تحت
الانقاض اخرجت فرق الانقاذ فتاه تبلغ من
العمر 17 عاما من تحت انقاذ مبنى منهار في
قهرمان مرعش بجنوب وسط تركيا وذلك بعد 248
ساعه من وقوع الزلزال ونقلت مقاطع فيديو
صور نقل الفتاه الى سياره اسعاف ومن ثم
الى المستشفى
موفد العربيه رصد احد الطرق المدمره بفعل
الزلزال في محيط مدينه غازي عنتاب وتظهر
الصور حجم وقوه الزلزال الذي ادى الى
تدمير شارع فرعي وتسبب في تشققات عميقه
تابعنا طيله الايام الماضيه اثر الزلزال
الكارثي الذي ضرب العديد من المدن جنوب
تركيا سنشاهد معهد الان احد اثار هذا
الزلزال كما تشاهدون هذا الشارع تغيرت
معالمه بالكامل وكما تشاهدون قوه الزلزال
كيف اثرت على هذا الشارع وهذه وهذا الدمار
الكبير الذي لحق بهذا الشارع في مدينه
غازي عنتاب يعني يمكن ان تشاهده حجم
الدمار الكبير الذي ادى الى هذه التشققات
وهذه الصدوع الكبيره
يعني الارض واضح انها يعني بشكل كبير
تاثرت تتحدث السلطان السلطات وخبراء
الزلازل ايضا عن يعني ازاحه للقشره
الارضيه بمسافه تقدر باكثر من سبعه امتار
ولكم ان تشاهدوا هذا المشهد في غازي عنتاب
غسان ابو اللوز العربيه
غازي عنتاب
جيبي موردون اعلن اليوم ان الاضرار
المباشره التي لحقت بالمنشات في تركيا
بسبب الزلزال قد تصل الى اثنين فاصل خمسه
بالمئه من نمو الناتج المحلي التركي اي ما
يعادل 25 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]
الهطاي مباشره معي من هناك مفرد العربيه
عمار الهندي عمار يعطيك الف عافيه جديد
المشهد الاغاثي ونقاظي من عندك في هذه
الاوقات واخر ما رصدته الكاميرا العربيه
المزيد من الجثث طالب والمزيد من الناس
التي تنتظر حتى هذه اللحظه ونحن في اليوم
الحادي عشر على هذا الزلزال المدمر ان
تخرج الجثامين والاشخاص المفقودين من تحت
الانقاض انا كنت رايت بام عيني في هذا
المكان في هذه الزاويه تحديدا قبل قليل
عدد من الجثث منهم للاطفال ولا تزال هنالك
جثث في المبنى الاخر وهؤلاء طبعا يعني
ساسالهم سريعا ومن بعيد لانهم يتناولون
الطعام
كم لديهم من الاشخاص لا يزال تحت الانقاض
صحتين والف هنا سريعا قديش الكم تحت
الانقاض قد ايش ضايل ناس تحت الانقاض
شخص واحد وانت خمس اشخاص شباب معروف في
هذا المبنى ولا هناك
يعني ست اشخاص لا يزالوا تحت الانقاض ان
شاء الله قريبا يعني الامور تكون على ما
يرام اشكركم جزيلا طالب لا تزال عمليات
البحث عن الجثث والمفقودين تحت الانقاض
مستمره ولكن مثلا في هذا المبنى الذي
شاهدنا اخراج يعني هذا الفريض فريق الذي
يظهر امامك في الشاشه طبعا هم يتناولون
الطعام منذ ساعات ربما لم ياكلوا هؤلاء
سوريين تطوعوا للبحث واخراج الجثامين من
تحت الانقاض ويعملون ليلا نهارا
ولا تتوقف اعمالهم انا ساتحرك ايضا الى
المبنى المجاور لان هنالك من ينتظر ايضا
يعني البحث عن الجثامين والمفقودين تحت
الالقاب كنت قبل قليل سريعا يعني اقصتك
قصه التقيت بشاب سوري اخبرني بانه يعمل في
معبر باب الهواء من الفريق الطبي المسؤول
عن نقل الاطفال من سوريا الى تركيا الذين
يحتاج العلاج وهم نقلوا 15 طفل من سوريا
خلال الفتره الماضيه ولديهم مشاكل صحيه
الى هنا الى مدينه انطاكيا وحينما حدث
الزلزال
تضررت المستشفيات وهم فقدوا حاليا يعني
فقدوا اثر هؤلاء الاطفال وبالتالي اسر
هؤلاء الاطفال في سوريا تتصل بهم تسالهم
ولا اجابه لديهم يعني فتشوا المستشفيات
ولم يجدوا فتشوا المقابر ولم يجدوا ولكن
يعني هم في حيره من امرهم الان كيف
يتصرفوا وبالتالي كانت يعني كان موضوع مهم
للغايه الرجل الذي قابلته كان مهموما جدا
وانا على ايه ايه حال ايضا ساتحدث الى هذا
الشاب وهو سوري من سكان هذه المنطقه وله
اقارب تحت هذا البناء واساله كم تبقى لديه
من اشخاص تحت الركام تحياتي يعطيك الف
عافيه انا بعرف انك تعبان ومرهق كنت تحدثت
اليك وين وصلوا كم شخص لك لا يزال تحت
الانقاض والله الى الان بقي سته اخرجنا
قرابه التسع اشخاص وبقي سته لنا في هذا
المبنى 21 شخص لحنا مش ضروري تحكي عربي
فصحى احكي براحتك باريحيه لوين وصلوا قديش
ضايل قدامهم تقريبا والله على ما يظهر حسب
مهمه
البواقر وحسب مهمه الاشخاص الذين يعملون
اذا ينتهي العمل الان في الساعه السادسه
ربما نحتاج يومين او ثلاثه حتى ينتهي
خلصوا على سته انتم راح تكملوا شغل ولا
راح نحاول اننا نكمل شغل بنحاول انه
المكان اذا انفتح مثلا قائد نحاول انه
ندخل البيت
نلاحظ انه اذا في احد في الداخل نحاول
سريعا بدي تحكيلي ولكن قبل ان نبدا لازم
ان ناخذ اذن من الجندرمون الموجودين تمام
تمام
ببساطه تروي لي قصه الطفل اللي اخرجتوه
كان حي وكان يرد وبعد ذلك توفاه الله لانه
ما استطعت والله اكثر ما قهرنا هذا الشاب
هذا الشاب من اليوم الاول كان نتحدث معه
بشكل واضح جدا ونخور ويصيح يعني قلنا انه
اسمه مقداد كان من اول يوم يتحدث بشكل
نظامي ولكن ما قدرنا ان نقدم له اي شيء
الركام كان واصل الى الطابق الخامس ربما
الايادي فقط موجوده لا يوجد اي معدات
تجينا نحن نحاول لانه نعمل اي شيء
اليوم خرج الله يرحمه
هلا الجثه تخرج تتعرف اليها وبعدين اخرج
نتعرف عليها هنا وبعض الجثث يتعرف عليها
من المكان لانه بعض الجثه ربما اصابتها
اذيه كبيره جدا تحللت ابن خالي خمسه اشخاص
لولا ان فتحنا وعرفنا انه هذا طابق وهذا
بيته ما تعرف ميزته للاسف الشديد طالب
سؤال يعني فقط لكي لا يفوت يعني اول شيء
الله يكون في العون حديث يعني استطراضا
لما تقوله وتسال يعني هذا الشاب هنالك
حديث في الاعلام التركي ان المرحله
المقبله ستكون سريعه جدا يعني جرف كبير
وسريع ومتواصل للابنيه المهدمه لانه في
روائح الجثث بدات تفوح وتسبب امراض للاسف
الى اي مدى هذا الكلام صحيح
انا في الحقيقه اشتم الروائح في يعني في
كل مكان حيث نقف بصراحه يعني سواء في
المبنى هناك او هنا حيث اقف نعم هنالك
روائح والجثث التي تخرج يعني جثث يعني
بدات تتحلل صراحه وبالتالي نعم هنالك
روائح يعني كثيره
ومساله الجرف والعمل السريع لا اعلم ما
مدى سماح الاسر التي تنتظر الجثامين ان
يسمحوا ان يسمحوا بها لانه انا اعتقد انه
هذا سيخلق نوع من التوتر لانه الناس لا
تزال كما قلت لك لليوم 11 تبيت في الشارع
الى جانب البنايات هؤلاء لم يغادروا مثلا
مع ساعات الليل تعيش يتدفق عليها ويعني
يبقوا حاضرين في المكان خشيه ان تضيع اي
جثه
عمار الهندي مفرد العربيه منها طيب شكرا
جزيلا لك عمار على كل هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه مستمره وفيها ايضا
قائد المنطقه الاولى في حرس الحدود
العراقي يؤكد ان الحدود مع ايران تشهد
مشاكل كثيره
اهلا بكم من جديد مباشره الى استونيا وهذا
المؤتمر الصحفي والكلمه لوزير الدفاع
الامريكي
باننا كنا قد اتخذنا قرارا في مدريد
مع مجموعه من الدول بصوره مستمره من اجل
تقديم
وجود وحضور مستمر من اجل مؤازره اوكرانيا
الامر الاخير الذي لا بد لي من الاشاره
اليه هو ان جزء من غزو روسيا
كان
يعتمدوا على ما قلته في اكثر من المناسبه
بانه اذا ما قامت روسيا بغزو اوكرانيا
فاننا سوف نقدم كل الدعم وسوف يكون لنا
حضور هنا
وسوف نفي بتعهداتنا في الفتره المقبله لذا
فاننا ملتزمون في
ما قلناه ويمكنكم ان ترهنوا على هذا الامر
هل ترغبون باضافه اي شيء
اذا لدينا فرصه لترحيل سؤال اخر
معدات الى اوكرانيا لكن جزءا كبيرا منها
لم يصل حتى الان
وكان الامير النيتو قد تذكر قد ذكر بان
العمليه الهجوميه قد توشف على الانطلاق
متى تعتقدون ان هذه المعدات العسكريه سوف
تصل الى اوكرانيا
متى سوف يكون لها ان تشكل فارقا وخاصه اذا
لم يتم وقف روسيا في هذه السنه وقد تكون
دول اوروبيه هي بعد ذلك
كما تعلمون روسيا قد بدات هذه العمليه
الهجوميه كما اسلفنا القول
ان روسيا ما تزال مستمره في
تجنيد اعداد كبيره من قواتها وهذه القوات
تفتقر الى التدريب الصحيح وتفتقر الى
القدرات القتاليه
تطور سير هذه المعركه
ونرى ان منطقه المخموسيه منطقه متنازع
عليها ونعتقد ان الامر سوف يكون على هذا
الحال لفتره من الزمن فيما يخص اذا ما كان
لنا القدره على ادخال هذه المعدات
العسكريه الى اوكرانيا هي مساله نعمل
عليها بصوره يوميه هذه المعدات التي تدخل
الى ميدان المعركه سوف يتم التدريب القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه عليها وبالمناسبه يتم
تدريب هذه القوات في اماكن متعدده
فمثلا سويت قد قدمت سي سي بي 9 وهي عباره
عن
حامله جنود
والمانيا ايضا قدمت تدريبا للقوات على
استخدام
على استخدام معدات عسكريه وعلى قدره
المناوره
ومركبات برادلي وبعض الاسلحه الهجوميه
ايضا يتم التدريب القوات الاوكرانيه عليها
في المانيا
وقدره المناوره في استخدام القوه الناريه
جمله من الاشياء تاتي في نطاق واحد
لدينا خطه تفصيليه حول كيفيه دفع الامور
التي تصبر في دعم اوكرانيا هذا هو عمل قيد
التطور لكنها مساله نكتفي بهذا القدر
للمؤتمر لهذا المؤتمر الصحفي ونواصل نشره
الخامسه من العربيه ادانا البيان المشترك
الاجتماعي مجموعه العمل الخليجيه
الامريكيه المشتركه الخاصه بايران ادانا
سياسات طهران المستمره في زعزعه استقرار
المنطقه والعالم بما في ذلك دعمها للارهاب
عبر نشرها الصواريخ المتطوره وانظمه
الطائرات بدون طيار وعبر البيان عن مخاوفه
من استمرار الطهران في تزويد الحوثيين
بالاسلحه الامر الذي يشكل تهديدا امنيا
خطيرا وفيما يخص البرنامج النووي الايراني
دعا البيان المشترك طهران الى وقف ما وصفه
بالاستفزازات النوويه التي تجاوزت
الاحتياجات المدنيه للبلاد وعليه حثه
مجموعه العمل الخليجيه الامريكيه ايران
على التعاون مع تحقيقات الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه خاصه تلك التي
عثر عليها في مواقع غير معلنه
كن على احراق واجهه احد المصارف اللبنانيه
في منطقه بدارو في العاصمه اللبنانيه
بيروت وقطع المحتجون السير في المنطقه
واشعر الاطارات المطاطيه امام فروع
المصارف وذلك بسبب الارتفاع الجنوني في
سعر صرف الدولار والتهرب المصارف من دفع
الودائع للمواطنين
كما شهدت مدينه صيدا وبلده بنايل البقاعيه
قطعا للطرق للاسباب نفسها
معي من بيروت لمزيد من المتابعه الدكتور
علي زبيب وهو مستشار قانوني لجمعيه
المذيعين دكتور علي اهلا وسهلا بك هل
اضراب المصارف مفهوم بالنسبه اليكم وما هي
خلفياته واين تقف حكومه الرئيس نجيب
ميقاتي من كل ما يجري الان
في الواقع سيدي الكريم المصارف اللبنانيه
امعنت في مخالفه جميع القوانين المرعيات
الاجراء منذ بدايه هذه الازمه الغير
مسبوقه في لبنان اي في السابع عشر من
تشرين من العام 2019 نتذكر جيدا انه في
هذا التاريخ قامت المصارف بالاغلاق لمده
13 يوما واخرجت مليارات الدولارات
السياسيين النافذين والمنتفعين ورؤساء
مجالس الاداره والمحظيين ومنعت وما زالت
تمتنع عن اعطاء القليل من ودائع الناس
فاللبنانيون او بالاحرى جميع المودعين في
لبنان حلم من اموالهم والمصارف كانت شريك
اساسي بذرائع تقدمت بها على مدى ثلاث
سنوات ونصف اكان عبر ذريعه ادانه او او
اقراض المصرف المركزي والذي ايضا يدعي
باقراض الدوله عمليه اغلاق المصارف هي جرم
قانوني فالمصارف تقدم خدمه عامه
الحركه الاقتصاديه في لبنان يضر بكل مواطن
ليس فقط على المستوى الاقتصادي والنقدي بل
على المستوى الاجتماعي ما نراه اليوم
للاسف سيكون ذريع على المصارف للعوده الى
الاقفال فهي اقفلت منذ اسبوع وهددت
بالاقفال التام
بس في سؤال يعني ما تقوله
المصري لبنانيه تقول نحن قمنا بادانه
ديننا المصرف المركزي هذه الاموال والمصرف
المركزي دينها للسلطه السياسيه في لبنان
التي بددتها والمشكله مشى ان المشكله عند
المصرف المركزي هل يمكن الاخذ بهذه
الذريعه بهذه الحجه
سيدي الكريم نحن بلبنان منقول هاي قصه
ابريق الزيت والشماعه التي تعلق عليها
المخالفات اليوم حضرتك اذا اردت ان تاخذ
قرضا بسيطا من اي مصرف تجاري فسيطلب منك
المصرف جميع انواع التامينات والضمانات
بينما قامت المصارف التجاريه
باقراض المصرف المركزي من دون اي ضمانات
وقد قام المصرف المركزي ايضا بمخالفه
لقانون النقد والتسليف باقراض الدوله ايضا
بدون ضمانات اليوم اذا في موده اودع مبلغ
من المال على سبيل الامانه اي وديعه وليست
استثمار ولا تجاره في المصرف فالمصرف هو
المسؤول الاول والاخير عن رد هذه الوديعه
وليس للمودع اي علاقه بالدوله اللبنانيه
او بالمصرف المركزي نحن لا
مهم بس فقط لنسفي دوله الوقت ولكن علاقتي
كموده هي بالمصري طيب الى اي الى اي مدى
الى اين ترى الامور ذاهبه خصوصا صاحب
الصرف باختصار
للاسف التدهور يعني وتيره سريعه جدا
للتدهور نحن كنا توقعنا هذا الامر وخاصه
ان المصرف المركزي يقوم بتضخيم الكتله
النقديه دون اي سند اكان بالعملات الصعبه
فهناك ثلاث مصادر اساسيه لادخال العمله
الصعبه التحويلات المغتربين وهي انخفضت
بشكل جذري والاستثمار الخارجي المباشر
والتصدير وهذه الثلاث عناصر مفقوده في
لبنان وبالتالي الانهيار مستمر ولا يجب
على المصارف ان تستمر بالاغلاق لان هذا
الامر
من بيروت الدكتوره علي هذا الامر اليوم في
الشارع يجب على القضاء ان يتحرك باسرع وقت
ممكن لان القضاء اللبناني هو الملاذ
الاخير المستشار القانوني لجمعيه المدعي
الدكتور علي زبيب شكرا جزيلا لك من بيروت
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه اشار قائد
المنطقه الاولى في قوات حرس الحدود
العراقيه اللواء حماد جزئي الى ان الحدود
العراقيه تشهد العديد من المشاكل نظرا لما
حدث سابقا من حرب مع ايران ووجود الاداعش
وبعض المجموعات المسلحه التي استغلت ذلك
مضيفا ان هناك مناطق لا تتواجد فيها اي
قوات من حرس الحدود التي تنوي الانتشار
بها قريبا
دائما حدود العراقيه حدود العراق بها
مشاكل هو خصوصا خلال
عثمان اكو حرب عراق وايرانيه هاي مناطق
حدود يعني ما ممسوكه يعني مناطق كلها يعني
اكو مناطق بها فراغ نعم
وهذا الحرب العصابه الداعش اثر عليها حدود
خصوصا السحب القوات هاي المناطق
واكو مجموعه غير مسلحين غير نظامين
استغلوا هاي الفتره حرب العصابات الداعش
استغلوا هاي المناطق
منطقه فارغه هسه ما بيها قوات الحدود او
قوات كشمركه او اي قوات النظاميه وحاليا
نحن نحاول ان شاء الله جهود راح نصرف
الجهود وان شاء الله راح نرجع لهاي
المناطق اللي فارغه وراح ننتشر بها قوات
الحدود
كما
قال اقلا في قوات حرس الحدود العراقيه
اللواء حماد دازاي في مقابله مع العربيه
انه سيتم تعيينه 2600 عنصر في المنطقه
الاولى تمهيدا لانتشارهم في المناطق التي
لا تشهد تواجدا امنيا عراقيا على الحدود
كائنات موجوده
[موسيقى]
2,621 درجه وظيفيه خصوصا للحدود المنطقه
الاولى المناطق اللي ما ممسوكه من قيمه
الحدود قوات الحدود راح ننتشرهم بهاي
المناطق
تتصاعد وتطورات المعركه الاشد في الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه وتحديدا معركه بخموت
حيث اعلنت هيئه الاركان العمل للقوات
الاوكرانيه عن تلقي خمسه عشره بلده في
باخمه هجمات صاروخيه وقصفا روسيا عنيفا
كما دمر الجيش الروسي مبنى سكنيا ما اسفر
عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص في منطقه بوغرافيس مع
محاوله التقدم في منطقتي اوبتني وكلشيفكا
وفقا القياديه الاوكراني السابق لجدانه
الذي وصف الاوضاع في دونتسك بشديده
الصعوبه
الخارجيه الروسيه اعلنت عن امكانيه
استهداف البنيه التحتيه الفضائيه المدنيه
التي تستخدمها الولايات المتحده
وحلفائها في الصراع باوكرانيا في سياق
الرد الروسي وقال نائب ومدير اداره منع
الانتشار وتحديد الاسلحه في الخارجيه
الروسيه ان موسكو تلفت الانتباه في
المحافل الدوليه الى اجراءات خطيره للغايه
تتجاوز الاستخدامات غير الضاره لتكنولوجيا
الفضاء وتحديدا ما تستخدمه الولايات
المتحده
وحلفاؤها لمكونات البنيه التحتيه المدنيه
في الفضاء بينها البنيه التحتيه التجاريه
لاغراض عسكريه
هذا واكد الرئيس البيلاروسيه الكسندر
لوكاشنكو ان بلاده لن تشارك في القتال في
اوكرانيا الى جانب القوات الروسيه الا اذا
تعرضت لهجوم وقال لوكاشينكو خلال حديث مع
وسائل اعلام اجنبيه ان بيلاروسيا ستسمح
للقوات الروسيه باستخدام اراضيها للدخول
الى الشمال الاوكراني في حال شعرت منسك
بتهديد من قبلك
وحمل لوكاشينكو واشنطن مسؤوليه فشل
اتفاقيات منسك بعد ان رفضت مع الدول
الغربيه منح روسيا الضمانات الامنيه لتجنب
الصراع واكد الرئيس البيلاروسي انه سيتحدث
مع نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين غدا
الجمعه لبحث التطوعات
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيه دي بتروكولي بهم
ايران بدعم روسيا بالمسيرات التي تستخدم
لقتل الشعب الاوكراني على حد قوله وخلال
لقاء مع وسائل اعلام عربيه اوضح قوليبا ان
التعاون مع اسرائيل ياتي في اطار مواجهه
التحدي الامني المشترك وهو ايران
الوضع تغير بشكل ماساوي ولدينا تحد امني
مشترك مع اسرائيل وهو ايران ولذلك يمكن
ادراك لماذا نتعاون معها الان ايران تدعم
روسيا بشكل واضح وتدعمها بالمسيرات التي
تستخدم ضد الشعب الاوكراني ولذلك نعتقد ان
هناك مجالا لتعزيز العلاقات مع اسرائيل
وفي اول زياره لمسؤول اسرائيلي رفيعه
لاوكرانيا وصل وزير الخارجيه اليكوهين الى
العاصمه
حيث يلتق يلتقي الرئيس الاوكراني
وذلك في الوقت الذي تطالب فيه كيف تل ابيب
باعطائها منظومات دفاع جوي ومنظمات اسقاط
للمسيرات لكن الاولى تتحفظ عن تلبيه هذه
المطالب بدريعه حاجاتها للتنسيق مع روسيا
في سوريا اولا
الى ينضم اليه لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه
قبل ان اسالك عن اخر التطورات الميدانيه
ما الذي حمله وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
الى القياده الاوكرانيه وما الذي سيسمعه
برايه
نعم تحياتي طالب في الحقيقه يعني اتى هذه
الزياره كتاكيد كما قال ديمتري كوليبا
وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني وكذلك وزير
خارجيه اسرائيل
كتاكيد على وقوف اسرائيل الى جانب
اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب طبعا
لاوكرانيا مطالب واضحه في اتجاه اسرائيل
في اطار الدعم العسكري الذي دائما مكانه
تطالب به اوكرانيا اسرائيل تحديدا مساله
الدفاع الجوي ما زالت اوكرانيا تعول على
الشهره التي تمتلكها القبه الحديديه
الاسرائيليه وفي ان تزود اسرائيل اوكرانيا
بانظمه الدفاع الجوي وما زال هذا الطلب
مطروح وطرحوا ايضا وزير الخارجيه اليوم
ديمتري كوليبا على وزير الخارجيه
الاسرائيلي طبعا لو لم يكن هنالك تعليق من
قبل حول ما اذا كان سيكون هنالك يعني دعم
في هذا الاطار للجانب الاوكراني ولكنه اكد
على ان اسرائيل تدعم اوكرانيا في ما سماها
السلام في اطار الامم المتحده الصيغه
الاوكرانيه تحديدا التي تطرحها اوكرانيا
من خلال القائمه المتحده بالنسبه الى
الوضع الميداني حذيفه قيادي عسكري اوكراني
وصف الاوضاع في دونسك بشديده الصعوبه هنا
السؤال هل بدات القياده الاوكرانيه تعترف
بشكل او باخر ان الكلمه العليا في دونتسك
باتت للروس تحديدا في مدينه بخما
نعم هذا صحيح الرئيس فلاديمير زيليسكي في
اخر خطاب له للشعب الاوكراني اقر بصعوبه
الوضع في باخبوت وقال ايضا ان الشركاء
الغربيين والمستشارين يعني من الدول
الصديقه ينصحون الجيش الاوكراني بالانسحاب
من باقمت وان لهذه المدينه ليس لها اي
اهميه استراتيجيه كبيره ولكن وجهه النظره
الاوكرانيه تختلف عن ذلك الاوكرانيون
يقولون انهم اذا ما انسحبوا من هذه
المدينه فهذا سيجعل الروسي يتقدمون
وسيطرون على المدينه وسوف يتقدمون اكثر من
ذلك الان تركيز الاتحاد الروسي كبير على
مدينه فوجود القوات الاوكرانيه في هذه
المدينه هو يعرقل كل العمليات العسكريه
التي يقوم بها الاتحاد الروسي هذا الزمن
مطلوب بالنسبه للجيش الاوكراني حتى وصول
الاسلحه والذخائر فالجيش الاوكراني الان
يعاني من نقص كبير جدا في الاسلحه والذخير
هذا طبعا بحسب افاده المسؤولين لذلك هم
يعتقدون ان الجبهه
يعني هم يعولون على اطول ممكن قد يستهلكه
الاتحاد الروسي في هذه المنطقه حتى يحصلوا
على الاسلحه المطلوبه طبعا هم ينفقون عدد
هائل من الذخائر فيها لذلك ينصحهم
الغربيون طبعا بالانسحاب ساكتفي بهذا
القدر العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا
حذيفه على كل هذه المتابعه
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
معهد
لعلوم المحيطات يكشف عن لقطات مصوره نادره
لس
فينه راقده في قاع المحيط الاطلسي منذ
عقود
اهلا بكم من جديد اتهم البرلمان الصيني
المشرعين الامريكيين بالتعدي على سياده
الدول الاخرى بعد ان اقرت الولايات
المتحده اجراءا يدينوا اختراق المنطاد
الصيني للمجال الجوي الامريكي وذكرت الصين
ان المنطاد كان خاصا بابحاث الطقس وهو
الادعاء الذي رفضته الولايات المتحده
مستشهده بان المنطاد كان يحمل معدات
للمراقبه
كما اعربت وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه عن
معارضتها الشديده لتصريحات وزراء دفاع حلف
الناتو والتي اتفقت على اعتبار بيكين
تهديدا
جاء ذلك بعد ان اكد الامين العام للحلف
يانسيس اتفاق دول الحلف على مفهوم جديد
للتخطيط الدفاعي لمواجهه ما وصفه بالسلوك
العدواني لروسيا وخطر الارهاب والتهديدات
من الصين
وفي اليابان قال وزير الدفاع الياباني
السابق والعضو في الحزب الحاكم اتسونوري
اونديرا ان المناطيد الصينيه ستكون سببا
لاقامه علاقات وتبادل المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه مع تايوان واضاف المسؤول
الياباني ان طريقه واحده يمكن لليابان من
خلالها مشاركه المعلومات مع تايوان وذلك
عبر الولايات المتحده موضحا انه زار
تايوان في يناير الماضي للتحدث حول
التهديدات التي تشكلها الصين على الجزيره
وياتي ذلك بعدما اعلنت الدفاع اليابانيه
في بيان لها انها تفترض ان مناطيد استطلاع
مسيره واجساما طائره صينيه رصدت في السابق
في مجالها الجويه
معي من القاهره لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع الدكتور احمد قنديل وهو البحث في
الشؤون الاسيويه دكتور احمد اهلا وسهلا بك
الى نشره الخامسه
المناطيض والاجسام الغريبه مستمره وبقوه
البعض يقول ان واشنطن تحضر سيناريو ما ضد
الصين وهذا السيناريو بات قريبا لذلك هي
تحاول عبر هذه الاخبار تهيئه الراي العام
الامريكي وكذلك الدولي لهذا السيناريو ما
رايك
مساء الخير على حضرتك الساده المشاهدين
اعتقد ان حضرتك محقه تماما ان الولايات
المتحده بتهيئ الراي العام الامريكي
والراي العامل الدولي لاعتبار الصين خصما
ومنافسا وتهديدا الاستراتيجيه للولايات
المتحده وفي نفس الوقت تحاول ايضا حشد
حلفائها في حلف الناتو لمواجهه الصين او
على الاقل احتواء صعودها العسكري
والاقتصادي في منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادي
لاول مره حلف الاطلنطي في قمه مدريد
الاخيره في يونيو الماضي ينظر الى بكين
باعتبارها التحدي المنهجي الاول للحلف
وداء ودي كانت المره الاولى منذ نشاه
الحلف في اواسط القرن الماضي وبالتالي ده
عايزه تطور استراتيجي مهم للغايه ربما
تكون التطورات الاخيره والتي منها حادثه
المنطاد الصيني وما صاحبها من التركيز
اعلامي شديد
الراي العامل العالمي لحرب بارده جديده
وتكتل غربي في مواجهه روسيا والصين بس
الدكتور احمد بعض المحللين ذهب ابعد من
ذلك انه مش مجرد حرب بارده ربما ساخنه ان
صح التعبير خصوصا وان البعض شبه ما يجري
الان من حادث المناطيض والاجسام الغريبه
بحوادث الانتراكس والجمره الخبيثه على
اعضاء الكونغرس ومجلس النواب وعمليات
الاخلاء والتي كانت تحضيرا للحرب الاندلو
امريكيه ضد العراق يعني كانت عشيه حرب
العراق هل هذا التشبيه مفهوم ام لا يعني
تشبيه مبتور
لا اعتقد يعني ان هذه التكهنات او
التوقعات بان تتحول المواجهه الحاليه الى
يعني مواجهه عسكريه بشكل مباشر صحيح ان
عدد من كبار جنرالات الجيش الامريكي توقع
ان تحدث هذه المواجهه في عام 20 25 والبعض
الاخر
اشار الى امكانيه حدوث ذلك في 20/27 ولكن
لا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده واجهزه صنع
القرار العسكري والامني تريد مواجهه
حقيقيه مع الصين في الفتره القادمه وانما
اعتقد ان هذا محاوله لحشد الحلفاء للقيام
بايه مهمه الاحتواء
للقوه الصينيه الصاعده الولايات المتحده
رغم يعني تاييدها لتايوان على سبيل المثال
لم تتعهد
بارسال اي قوات عسكريه او وضع اي قوات على
الارض
رغم كل ما قيل عن تاييدها لاستقلال تايوان
وما الى ذلك وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذه هذا
الموقف مؤشر على
عدم رغبه واشنطن في الدخول في ايه بواجهات
عسكريه خاصه وان موازين القوى في المنطقه
بترجح ان القوه العسكريه الصينيه ربما
تتفوق في هذه الساحه القتاليه يعني في
مواجهه الولايات المتحده طيب ساكتفي بهذا
القدر من القاهره الدكتور احمد قنديل
البحث في الشؤون الاسيويه شكرا جزيلا لك
على هذه المشاركه
من رسميه ايرانيه ان النجم السابق للمنتخب
الايراني لكره القدم علي دائي الذي دعم
الاحتجاجات في ايران لم يتمكن من المشاركه
في حفل توزيع جوائز الفيفا بسبب حظر السفر
وذكرت وكاله انباء الطلبه الايرانيين اسنا
في تقريرها انه قبل ايام قليله دع الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم رسميا علي دائي لحضور
حفل توزيع جوائز افضل لاعبي الفيفا لهذا
العام لكن حينها لم يكن واضحا ما اذا كان
سيسمح لداء بمغادره البلاد ام لا وبحسب
هذه الوكاله شبه الرسميه فان المتابعات
بهذا الخصوص تظهر ان علي دائما ممنوع من
السفر الى خارج البلاد
اعلنت السلطات نيوزلنديه ارتفاع حصيله
ضحايا اعصار نيوزيلندا الى خمسه قتله هذا
فيما تم اجلاء اكثر من عشره الاف شخص من
منازلهم بسبب الفيضانات التي خلفها
الاعصار جابريال وحضرت السلطات سكان
المناطق الشرقيه المتضرره من مرور الاعصار
من ان مزيدا من الامطار الغزيره ستهطل في
الساعات المقبله
كشف معهد هودز هول لعلوم المحيطات عن
لقطات مصوره ونادره تظهر سفينه الركاب
الشهيره تايتنك راقده بقاع المحيط الاطلسي
بعد عقود من اكتشاف حطامها واضاف المعهد
ان لقطات التي وصفها بالمدهشه مدتها 80
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه المفصله وفيناكم بها من
العربيه اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]